all is not well in the kingdom of smart
we are broke my lord and in the South
several dominions are getting desperate
what are we to do place a tax on cow
sire no no tax cut for Miller's we
should build a new cathedral how about
closing the borders no what do you have
to say speak up if I may be so bold your
grace we urgently need an innovation
strategy for smart specialization what
are you talking about it means that we
have hungry dwarfs wanting to be feared
excited goblins longing to be unleashed
and sleeping giants ready to be awakened
hungry dwarves yes sir you certainly
remember our dwarf craftsmen in the
mountains producing quality shoes which
were once so popular but now people buy
cheap shoes and the dwarfs are
struggling offer them a new challenge
help them join forces with the artists
goblins and young engineers and they
could do great things again ok ok but
what about the goblins they have some
crazy ideas but neither the guilds nor
the bankers will risk investing in them
your excellency you could easily unleash
the goblins potential if you back them
at the beginning others would trust them
then they could use their knowledge and
skills to develop new techniques and
thus help the Giants hmm the famous
Giants why are they sleeping they fell
asleep because they haven't noticed the
world is changing and needs new ideas we
need to wake them up get them together
with other creative people and help them
to focus their energies on improving
their methods and setting themselves
apart from our competitors interesting
but how do we do this your majesty
unfortunately you cannot dictate
innovation however you can certainly
cultivate it through entrepreneurial
discovery this cannot be done from
inside the palace you have to come out
and listen to what they have to tell you
can convince them to work together and
use the smart Oriole funds to
bought them in their innovation efforts
we have all written it up for you this
manuscript explains how smart
specialization can work but beware this
is not a magical solution it needs
leadership commitment collaboration and
future orientated investment and faith
in our future good young lady let's
innovate together let's go for smart
specialization